[Music]
working with this particular cast was a
dream uh they're all irish in various
ways judy dench's parents are from there
catching about from just across the
border in the south jamie dorner from
belfast here in heinz from belfast very
close to where i grew up and young jude
hill from just outside belfast they're
all great
jokers they're very playful very
generous with each other very generous
with sharing elements of their own
experience and that was a great way of
bonding and finding the family feeling
that was so critical to making this
story work to believe that they loved
each other and that they argued with
each other and did all the things that
families do
working with cannes
was a dream come true and the entire
cast was just so lovely
and
as soon as we all saw each other that
was an immediate click and we all bonded
together so easily
yeah it's a remarkable beautiful bunch
of people generally
and this room and to work with ken was
uh not just a thrill but it's a kind of
an honor because he's a he's a master of
many crafts
in a weird way because it was such a
small cast and such a small crew it just
really did feel like a little family
very quickly it was a weird time because
it was in the middle of covid so we
weren't able to fulfill all the usual
social protocols that you fulfill when
doing a movie and sort of endlessly at
the end of the day you know meeting up
for a drink at the end of day or going
out for dinners and stuff we were sort
of denied all of that because of covet
situation but i feel that as a result
that sort of
brought us even closer and we bonded in
an even more sort of intimate way when
we were on set you know and
um all of our downtime felt really sort
of precious or something because we
weren't getting to do the normal sort of
see outside of work stuff so it sort of
elevated it i just remembered though
when we so one of the first days it was
like a heat wave as well our first few
days when we were rehearsing and things
that ken had us playing rounders with
everybody but remember we had to wear
gloves because of covid
and because it was so hot
it was just like this really sweaty
sweaty plastic gloves but uh and then
you and then
i almost killed jamie
i whacked the balls straight in your
stomach
before filming we had a game of riders
no i wasn't there oh well we had a game
of rounders and
i'd say i was probably the best there
you know
got a big swing
and it was pretty fun just to bond with
the big crew and all the other other
cast members
yeah sadly i wasn't invited to that game
over and over and i'm still trying to
get over it
[Music]
i think mcdowell wants us to leave
belfast what do you want i want you and
granny to come too
where there is love
there is hope we can give these boys a
better chance than we ever have the new
york times raves belfast is cinematic
and lustrous
it's the best picture of the year and
now it's been nominated for seven
academy awards including best picture of
the year no other movie moves us like
belfast ready pg-13 go with your heart
in theaters now